welcome welcome
you are my pick for james bond but we're
not here to talk about that
i'm just throwing it out there in the
united states
you're my pick for james bond we'll
discuss it later we'll discuss it later
let's begin let's talk about knuckles
let's talk about knuckles because how
did you decide the voice that you were
going to use it sounds very sinister he
also has an endearing side too how did
you decide the voice you were going to
do for knuckles
uh you know it's a process
we basically discussed uh what who he
was where he came from you know english
isn't his first language he comes from
kinder and he's this sort of tribesman
so he wanted to figure out a way you
know to make him sound like he you know
he's sort of struggling with the english
language a little bit i i wanted to do a
squeaky voice like because he's so big
of medicine i wanted to do you know like
a squeaky voice up here but the director
didn't go for that uh unfortunately
i grew up playing video games i remember
sonic vividly and i remember the
introduction of knuckles the character
so just like in this sequel everybody's
excited but he is a villain um but a
lovable one at that there's something
about villains that you identify with
because you capture it well on screen is
that fair to say yeah you're right you
know i do enjoy playing villains because
for the most part they're well written
you know yeah they tend to say things
people only think
uh and and i and i enjoy i enjoy that
process
you act we know that you produce but i'm
very fascinated by your music career
what's it like when everyone's dancing
to your playlist you dress and what
makes a good dance song to you well look
you know it's almost a spiritual thing
when a dj has the sort of pulse of
everyone in a room it's quite
uplifting it's spiritual you know once
you get into that groove you know
because to play one song that everybody
likes is a thing that's what i think
people overlook about djing is to try
and get everyone to a heightened place
right
for me a good song is one that has a
little bit of a journey you know a
little bit of peaks
and some lows
and always a good bass line always has
to have the bass you know
gail you need to come out with me one
time man come on
let's do it yes
we'd love to
you don't have to ask us twice yeah i
fear i might be a little bit of a
wallflower but you know i'll grab the
drinks oh no tony we're gonna get you on
the dance floor idris could probably do
it uh all right so you've played you've
played world leaders you're playing an
animated character now you are a dj in
real life uh any possibility that you
could see yourself adding secret agent
to that list i'm thinking in particular
of double o not five
not six not eight but seven please say
yes you know it's one of these um rumors
that
i i'm proud to be considered you know a
contender for bond of course there's you
know like it's an incredible
compliment to me but as a career choice
it's not one that i've pursued you know
i have my character luther which is a
detective and we just started making the
movies now and in my head it sort of
covers the same sort of real estate but
it's my character as opposed to you know
james bond so
um yeah i haven't really i've never
really pursued this rumor you know
listen if it was offered to me i'd
heavily consider it but i don't think it
will be it's it's it's not you know it's
not on the cards
now just i want to take a little bit of
a left turn um you know i love that you
kind of live your relationship out loud
and as a married man i i admire that so
i just want to ask you what's the key to
a happy relationship you could not get
enough uh honesty
and conversation like literally the
dialogue has to continue you have to
question examine
reason
everything and it's continuous you know
every every you shed your skin you've
got to keep shedding your skin
learning new things that's what i think
the success is the movie opens tonight
we are just know that we're cheering you
on thank you so much it's a great movie
it's a family movie uh have fun i want
you guys to see it it's great it's great
fun
it's great fun so remember we talked to
jim carrey who's also in the movie so
the two of them together it's nice
legendary duo i love that how the accent
of knuckles the sonic character is not
american and not british he just
knuckles
coming from somewhere else yeah no doubt
about it and sonic 2 is in theaters
right now so make sure you check it out
it is an awesome film